Let's now deal with this Q and unstuff.
So we have reached a new low where Donald
Trump will praise anyone.
Absolutely.
Anyone who says anything positive about him.
There is this.
Thing I hate to even call it that, called
que anon.
Some people call it kanon.
Some people call it cannon.
Some people call it Kwanten anyway.
Q And on.
Q And on is a radical right conspiracy theory.
It involves a deep state plot supposedly against
Donald Trump.
A group or a person or an entity named Q claims
to have classified information about it, has
made all sorts of allegations.
It really hasn't been worth our time to cover,
but it is slowly infected.
Trump rallies and it is slowly infected.
Trump ism.
And it is spread through Trump supporters.
And it got to the point where yesterday Donald
Trump was actually asked about this during
his press briefing.
And Trump seems to like.
Q and on and almost endorse.
Q And on, despite claiming that he doesn't
actually know anything about them.
Take a look at this.
During the pandemic that he would not do that
thing appears to be gaining a lot of followers.
Can you talk about what you think about that
and what you have to say to people who are
following this movement right now?
Well, I don't know much about the movement
other than I understand they like me very
much, which I appreciate.
But I don't know much about the movement.
I have heard that it is gaining in popularity.
And from what I hear is these are people that
when they watch the streets of Portland, when
they watch what happened in New York City
in just the last six or seven months.
But this was starting even four years ago
when I came here almost four years.
Can you believe it?
These are people that don't like seeing what's
going on in places like Portland and places
like Chicago and New York and other cities
and states.
And I've heard these are people that love
our country and they just don't like seeing
it.
So I don't know really anything about it other
than they do supposedly like me.
And they also would like to see problems in
these areas, like especially the areas that
we're talking about, go away.
I've heard these people love our country.
This is really close to an endorsement of
Q and on.
If you can imagine something so outrageous,
then the reporter smartly follows up and says,
well, you know.
Q And on claims that you, Donald Trump, are
saving the world from a satanic cult of pedophilia
and cannibalism.
Is that something that you're doing?
And Trump still sort of says, hey, you know
me as the savior of the world, that that sounds
pretty good.
Trump can't get away from anybody who says
anything positive about Trump, no matter how
outrageous or laced with conspiracies.
Take a look.
Every it is this belief that you are secretly
saving the world from the satanic cult, pedophiles
and cannibals.
Does that sound like something you are behind?
I haven't I haven't heard that.
But is that supposed to be a bad thing or
a good thing?
You know, if I can help save the world from
problems, I'm willing to do it.
I'm willing to put myself out there.
And we are actually we're saving the world
from a radical left philosophy that will destroy
this country.
And when this country is gone, the rest of
the world would follow.
The rest of the world would follow.
The president is certainly not saying that's
insane and I denounce it.
Okay.
The president is certainly not saying anything
that they say about me is false.
What Trump is saying is they sound like good
people.
They like me.
They love our country.
And they say I'm saving the world from things
while I am saving the world from things.
That doesn't sound so bad.
I really hope that people understand how absolutely
outrageous this is.
This is similar to a president endorsing pizza
gate.
This is similar to a president embracing birther
is.
Oh.
Trumps.
Oh, yikes.
Okay.
Yeah, well, birther ism that that, too.
I read that Jeb Bush was horrified that Donald
Trump seemed to endorse.
Q.
This is not Jeb Bush's Republican Party anymore,
but Jeb Bush does bear responsibility for
this being the Republican Party as of today.
And I think that that's really where I want
to focus our time.
This is why I keep bringing up that after
Donald Trump is gone, whenever it is, whether
it's January or January of 2025 or, as Trump
recently suggested, getting a third term January
of 2029.
That's a joke, by the way.
The Republican Party is really going to have
to figure out what do we do with the Trump
lists?
If Trump loses in November, he will lose despite
60 million or 62 or 64 or 66 million people
voting for him.
What does the Republican Party do with those
60 plus million people who want Trump reelected?
What does the country do with the 60 million
people is a different question, which I don't
have an answer to.
But as far as the Republican Party, this is
what happens when you welcome any lunatic
who is willing to vote against Democrats for
decades.
The anti-abortionist.
Come on in.
The homophobes.
The cartoonish libertarians.
Come on in.
The white nationalists, the conspiracy theorists,
the religious nut selling silver solutia.
Right.
Everybody, come on in.
Well, they're here now.
And they selected Trump in the 2016 primary
and they're reaping what they've sown.
And oh, now Jeb Bush doesn't like it.
Colin Powell doesn't like it as far as Jeb
Bush.
If Jeb Bush is concerned about what he's hearing
from Donald Trump, come out publicly and say
we have to vote for Joe Biden.
Where's George W. Bush?
We know George W. Bush is not endorsing Trump.
He's not participating in the presidential
election and is reportedly disturbed by some
of the things Donald Trump has done and said,
why doesn't George W. Bush come out and say,
for the sake of our country, we must all vote
for Joe Biden this time around?
And then lastly on the press briefing, just
does like a cherry on top.
A Trump still seems to think that stealth
airplanes, which, of course, they're invisible
to radar.
Trump still seems to think that they're invisible
to the naked eye.
Take a look at this.
Very difficult.
I was asking a pilot, what do you think is
better?
This one.
That one talking about Russian planes, Chinese
planes.
They said, well, the advantage we have is
you can't see it.
So when we're fighting, they can't see us.
They say that sounds like a really big advantage
to me.
This is where we are today.
And we may have four more years of this.
It's a real possibility.
It's up to us to prevent it.
We're going to have more on this on The David
Pakman Show Instagram, which is David Pakman
show on Instagram.
You can follow me on Instagram.
Why would you follow me?
I don't know.
But you can see pictures and updates of my
urban garden, my CUCs and my Zip's.
I've got eight inches, 10 inches foot long.
It's crazy what's going on out there with
my CUCs and Zook's